in the last video using the accrual
basis for accounting we had $200 of
income in month 2 but over that same
month we saw that we went from having
$100 in cash to having negative $100 in
cash so we actually lost $200 in cash so
how can we reconcile the fact that it
looks like we made $200 in income but we
lost $200 in cash and that
reconciliation is going to be done with
the cash flow statement so most cash
flow statements they'll start so I'm
going to do a cash flow statement right
over here so they'll start with your net
income or actually they'll start with
the cash that you started out with
so they take you from this cash balance
to that cash balance so this they'll say
something like starting cash starting
cash we know is at is $100 and then
they'll say well in the most naive
interpretation of things your net income
in theory should be cash you're getting
or at least it's some type of profit
you're getting some assets in the door
or at least your counting is if you're
getting some assets in the door so then
you're having you have your net income
your net income during the period and
here we'll literally just take whatever
is reported from the income statement so
over there we get 200 net income and now
we have to do the reconciliation part
because if this was all cash that you
were getting then you should have $300
in cash at the end of the period which
we clearly don't have so we have to
reconcile by looking at the changes in
different things on the balance sheet so
over here we have a net change in
accounts receivable so we have an
increase in accounts receivable so I'll
call it a our increase a are short for
accounts receivable just to save some
space so let's just think about it when
you have an increase in accounts
receivable you're kind of letting people
owe you money you're letting people owe
you $400 if you if you didn't let them
oh you that would have been cash so
you're kind of pushing back the time
that you're getting cash this is $400
that you didn't get that maybe you could
have gotten if you didn't allow I guess
this person to to delay when they paid
you so an increase in accounts
receivables is actually less cash than
you would have otherwise
gotten so this is negative 404 your cash
flow and we had no other changes we I
don't even address accounts payable here
that's that's essentially pushing back
owing people uh paying other people
paying your vendors money but I don't
even address that in the previous
example no other changes in our
liabilities so this is the only
adjustment we make and so if we do this
and sometimes this will be called a use
of cash or subtraction from or there's
different ways that it's different it
can be phrased in different contexts but
over here you'll have your net cash from
operations cash from operations I'll
just say opps and over here you can see
when you add it all when you when you
will just the cash from operations
200-400 so I'm just adding this part
right over here you have negative 200
and so you're starting cash is 100 you
have negative 200 cash from operations
and this is what you would have also
gotten if you had done cash accounting
you would have had negative 200 cash
from operations and then if you start
with 100 you use $200 in cash your
ending cash your ending cash will be
negative 100 so this little thing that I
just created here this little
reconciliation between the positive 200
and income and the negative 200 of cash
and showing where we got from this
starting point in cash to this ending
point this is a cash flow statement so
you now know the three major financial
statements